willkommen zu einer neuen Folge meines
Podcasts CL Plus und heute habe ich
einen Gast hi Christian vielen Dank für
die Einladung sie sind seit 2011 im
Vorstand eines daxkonzerns der Deutschen
Telekom hast du da Chat GPT benutzt für
die Anmoderation oder
ja klappt ja doch nicht so gut man muss
noch mal drauf schauen korrigieren nicht
jede Formulierung ist so wie man sie
haben will manchmal ist auch ein
sachlicher Fehler drin aber es ist schon
relativ weit ja da kennt sich aber
jemand ganz schön gut aus die Lächeln
schon sagen Sie es was was was was fällt
ihen auf ich habe das Gefühl du schiebst
h eine ganz schön ruhige Kugel kann das
sein das gefällt mir gut Christian hier
bisschen Ampel bisschen Podcast bisschen
ausruhen deutsche Vita nicht schlecht so
würde ich ich das die positiver
Erzählung machen ja apropos wow huch da
wie die Zeit verfliegt da war eine
schöne erste Folge fand ich oder es war
einfach Bullshit vielen lieben Dank
Christian